hello
my name is manfred weiss and i am
working at the helmholtz center in
berlin
my name is phil de luna and i'm a
program director at the national
research council of canada my name is
constantine and i'm a science
communication officer for the research
project transfer science
my name is sabina kunst i'm the
president
of the humboldt university suberlin i'm
jorgen i'm a science communicator and
biologist
and together with the high art bureau
i'm organizing the uraniac muslim
on november 5th i'm claudia vit i'm a
co-director of the digital society
initiative at the university of zurich
i'm bazad
i'm the ceo and co-founder of reasonable
hello my name is jennifer decker and i
represent the national
research council of canada in germany
we're excited to be part of berlin
science week
i'm theo from athens greece i'm the
founder of psycho
hi i'm chris neuvel from paulder
institute in berlin
we are happy to participate at this
year's berlin science week in the center
of berlin
at the center of berlin science week so
great to see you all at urban science
week bye
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you